على الاقل في هذه الساعه ليلى هدوء مشوب
بالحذر الشديد على طول خط الحدود ولكن
لنفس على الواقع ما الذي يحدث في هذه
الايام وفق الكثير من المراقبين والمحللين
العسكريين الاجواء
جدا بارده سقيع ولكن الضباب يغطي
كافه المناطق على طول خط الحدود يعني عند
هذه التله هذه مزارع شبعه المحتله من
خلفها جبل الشيخ الذي اكد الجيش
الاسرائيلي واعترف بالامس واليوم ان هناك
كان استهداف
بصاروخ ومسيره اتجاهه ولكن يعني البعض
يقول وفق المحللين انه عندما يزداد الضباب
تزداد عمليات حزب الله لانه لا يكون هناك
رصد وامكانيه لاكتشاف اي مسيره او حتى
تسلل بسبب هذا الضباب من قبل جنود الجيش
الا الاسرائيلي بالطبع منذ ساعات صباح هذا
اليوم دوت صافرات الانذار على طول كامل خط
الحدود على الاقل خمس مرات وفي ساعات مساء
امس وفي ساعات متاخره تحديدا دوت صافرات
الانذار سبع مرات كان هناك اعتراف بسقوط
اربع قذائف صاروخيه في منطقه شلومي لكنها
سقطت في مناطق مفتوحه ايضا في منطقه جبل
الشيخ ومرج اليوت كان هناك صافرات خشيه من
تسلل مسيرات لكن اتضح بعد ذلك ان التشخيص
كان خاطئ ايضا في ساعات مساء امس كان هناك
صاروخ مضاد للدروع في منطقه عرب العرامشه
التي دوت فيها صافرات الانذار على الاقل
خمس مرات في ساعات مساء الا امس ايضا خلال
يوم امس كان هناك تاكيد من الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه تم اعتراض جسم مشبوه جنوب
منطقه راس الناقوره اي في الجليل الغربي
ولكن تم اسقاط هذا الجسم الذي لم تسميه
فوق البحر في المقابل الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول انه قصف بنى تحتيه عمليه حسب وصفه في
بلده بيت ليف في الجنوب اللبناني وانه كان
يتواجد داخل احد هذه البنى او المباني عدد
من عناصر حزب الله وانه تم استهدافهم ايضا
كان هناك قصف على منطقه وبلده دير عامس اي
ولكن ايضا كان هناك ليله امس وحتى ساعات
صباح هذا اليوم قصف على بلدات كبلد الخيام
التي تظهر الان عبر عدسه الكاميرا وايضا
طير حرفه وحوله وراس الناقوره وكانت ايضا
صافرات الام ار قد دوت على الاقل مرتين في
هذه المناطق وتحديدا في جبل الشيخ ولكن في
هذه الساعه على الاقل منذ المقابله
الاخيره ليله حتى هذه الساعه لم تدوي
صافرات الانذار ولكن نحن نتحدث عن هدوء
مشوب بالحضر الشديد واضح